philibert mon chéri mon chéri mon chéri
ce genre de familiarité déjà on n'a pas
couché ensemble du mois de toi
personnellement tué pour où tu es contre
la réforme de l'enseignement à moi je
suis ni pour ni contre
je suis pour la suppression pure et
simple de l'école qu'est-ce qu'on
bricole on perd du temps on se met dans
des détails en avance ah oui alors
qu'est ce que tu fais tu rédige
d'émotion à ça sur youtube mes moyens a
causé leur trace déjà si tu voyais
comment j'écris contestation tu aurais
une idée de l'étendue du malaise
universitaire parce que ça commence par
un cul et ça finit tout à la main c'est
joli travail d'artisan à toi à moi tant
pis si je meurs ce soir mais un 10 mois
qu'est ce qui te choque toi dans
l'enseignement à moins tout non mais en
détail en détail tout il ya un truc que
j'ai jamais pu encadrer moi c'est
l'absence de dialogue
est-ce que tu 7 1 avant à l'école y en
avait pour le professeur y avait plus
qu'à val d'oise parler et ça n'arrêtait
pas il arrivait le matin il commençait à
faire pousser des haricots dans une
soucoupe sans nous demander si on
préférait pas mêlant dire non après il y
avait une histoire de fins envoyé passé
ravaillac avec un couteau comme ça entre
les dents immédiatement après envoyé
patients henri iv avec le même couteau
parce que qu'ils ont pas beaucoup de
matériel mais lui il avait dans le dos
après il y avait un train qui partait de
dijon plein pot de moutarde y avait un
autre train qui partait de francfort
bourré de saucisses et nous il fallait
qu'on dise combien de temps ça mettrait
pour que les saucisses rattrape la
moutarde dans une assiette au buffet de
la gare dans nos rangs car elles
répondent pas comme ça tu arrives à la
puberté tu as déjà d'evariste comprend
et maintenant à maintenant c'est pas
pareil il a droit à cinq minutes par
jour comme les copains c'est la
participation qu'on appelle alors quand
il a fini de nous pomper l'air avec lady
cotylédons les vases communicants je
sais pas ce que c'est ça doit être des
types qui sentent pas bien qu'ils se
téléphone alors c'est à nous et nous on
n'y a pas ce qu'on sait faire alors jojo
il ya pas un sniffer de la colle moi j'y
apprends à faire défendre avec ses
bretelles mais ne pas nous et ça c'est
la sig dans l'eau il faut dire qu'il a
plus de mal lotis tient le temps alors
et lucho posera jusqu'où ça pouvait
aller on lui à crédit haut les mains le
potin louis tomber et là on lui a appris
à faire des claquettes
le samu est arrivé tout de suite
goethe ou non j'ai pas tout lyon chez un
truc que j'ai jamais pu encadrer moi
c'est le coût des examens
tu trouves ça morel toi hein monsieur
non la pleine force de l'âge qui s'amuse
à poser des questions à des plus petits
comme lui alors qu en plus attention il
ya plus tant droit de regarder les
réponses dans le bouquin et qu'est ce
que vous avez fait elle m'a regards sont
issus le polonia leur beauté le bouquin
et maintenant il ya que nous qu'on a le
droit de regarder les réponses de da
c'est rien mais ça aide
l'autre jour il me fait kiseka révoqué
l'édit de nantes
j'ai sauté sur le bouquin devenu tu
appris l'art et sa réponse c'est les
chantiers de l'atlantique
oui mais alors supposons qu'ils vous
poser une question dont la réponse à
touba dans le bouquin alors vous êtes
cuit pas du tout c'est prévu c'est dans
un cas comme ça on sait comme vous on
fait comme les grands le document on
procède d'un sondage d'opinion dans la
classe vous les grands comme vous aviez
et la difficulté à avoir des idées
personnelles vous attendez qu'un sondage
et puis vous mettez du du côté où il ya
le plus gros pack et nous on fait pareil
l'autre jour il nous dit jeunes changent
mais vous poser une question très simple
tu as intérêt à fermât fin parce que là
c'est hypocrite et menteur c'est bête la
scène élie voici la question jeunes gens
à votre avis est ce que l'intelligence
de l'homme est une manifestation de la
présence de dieu chez charles d'accord
mais ça il ya des moments on a mangé un
peu lourd on n'est pas en train tu sais
alors on a fait un sondage dans la
classe et comme réponse à donner
36% de 15 2% de et le restent sans
opinion
tu vois aussi contre les grands d'accord
alors rouge tu attends moi c'est cela
qui sont des classes terminales que je
fais ça tu veux pas l'ignorer en ce
moment en ce moment alors en ce moment
c'est plein à craquer on ne sait plus du
tout où mettre les élèves en terminale
alors t'as une solution à machine salut
theory puisqu'elle s'est plaint en
terminale les horizons qu'à faire comme
moi il faut rester en sixième moi ça
fait quatre ans que j'y suis je me suis
jamais senti aussi bien m'en viens
l'autre jour on a une visite médicale je
prends un poil de cholestérol on vient
de leur pas le nom du réalisateur mais
je pète le feu
moi je peux te la fais aurait pas me
pousser beaucoup pour quoi je redoute me
7e diam
[Musique]